et pour parler de la stratégie des tests
ou plus précisément pour parler des
tests salivaires nous sommes avec
alexandra prieux pdg de skills elle
bonsoir est avec vous francs que molina
directeur de recherche au cnrs merci à
tous les deux d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors fin mai alexandre
apprieu vous étiez intervenu sur notre
antenne pour parler d'un nouveau test de
dépistage du coronavirus il s'appelle
isikoff simple et rapide réalisée par
prélèvement salivaire alors où est ce
que vous en êtes aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il est commercialisé
alors aujourd'hui le test est
commercialisé donc nous avons poursuivi
nos recherches et le test a été marqué
ces oeufs à la fin du mois de juin donc
aujourd'hui le test physique offre est
commercialisée en europe et dans le
reste du monde alors franck molina vous
avez travaillez vous aux côtés du comité
scientifique au printemps dernier avec
telles difficultés vous avez rencontré
pourquoi l'autorisation des tests
salivaires at-elle traîner tout d'abord
j'étais au comité caire donc qui venait
en soutien du conseil scientifique et
qui depuis s'est arrêtée d'ailleurs est
effectivement dans notre vision on
essayait de renforcer la stratégie de
tests avec des tests complémentaires qui
rit un peu plus sur le terrain qu'ils
répondraient un peu plus facile
facilement d'abord en termes
d'acceptation de la population mais
aussi qui donne des réponses plus
rapides donc des tests un peu plus ou
alors alexandre appris aujourd'hui donc
votre vos tests sont distribués dans le
monde entier en europe en france
hatem telles doses sont ils distribués
aujourd'hui pour le moment c'est assez
limité en france c'est vrai que nous
vendons principalement à l'étranger et
c'est lié au fait que la france a donc
voulu faire des tests supplémentaires
pour s'assurer qu'il était opportun de
travailler sur prélèvement salivaire
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
franck molina finalement ce délai assez
long pour mettre sur le marché un
nouveau test un test salivaire qui même
s'il est peut-être un peu moins fiables
pourrait effectivement désengorger les
les laboratoires aujourd'hui comment est
ce que vous le comprenez tout d'abord un
peu la prudence parce que la nouveauté
entraîne engendre souvent la prudence et
c'est bien normal
on a essayé de faire les choses le plus
vite possible pour répondre à l'urgence
de la première vague et finalement
lorsque le test est sorti on s'est
retrouvé avec des niveaux de validation
très intéressant qui montrait l'utilité
d'un tel test mais comme alexandra le
disaient certains ont souhaité renforcer
et on peut comprendre c'était cela le
problème c'est que les et les cas se
sont ralenties dans le sud de la france
et ces renforcements ne pouvait pas être
fait ici sur montpellier donc c'est un
petit peu tardé dans l'été mais en
dehors de tout ça c'était sous la vue
sont utilisés partout sur un sur la
planète dans différents endroits et ont
montré leur efficacité
on sait qu'il faut les utiliser assez
rapidement en complément de ce qui
existe déjà
justement en termes de fiabilité
alexandre à apprieu qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire avec certitude
aujourd'hui sur ces tests salivaires
alors c'est difficile de parler de
parler de certitude aujourd'hui enfin
plus tôt vendredi donc la hs a déclaré
qu'il était opportun de d'utiliser les
tests salivaires dans un certain nombre
de dépistages sont bien sûr nous nous
félicitons et souvent nous sommes bien
entendu très heureux et à côté de cela
il ya un certain nombre d'études au
niveau international qui montre
également que les tests salivaires
peuvent être utiles et peuvent être très
efficaces dans un grand nombre de cas
c'est à dire quand j'ai des symptômes
alors là on est sûr à 100% que le test
va réagir et va indiquer que nous sommes
positifs le 100 % fin je pense que
ferait on pourra en parler mieux que moi
mais c'est des choses qui sont toujours
délicat à faire en biologie quel que
soit le test d'ailleurs et quel que soit
le prélèvement
mais aujourd'hui oui les tests
salivaires sont des tests qui peuvent
être en effet très performant pour les
personnes symptomatique
et comme nous l'avons vu nous chez nous
et comme d'autres personnes l'ont vu
autre part dans le monde également pour
les bains
anna symptomatique alors franck molina
qui peut le faire aujourd'hui ce test
salivaire
ou est-ce qu'on peut le faire plus
précisément donc aujourd'hui comme on
l'a dit mais dans différents pays et les
gens le pratiquent déjà
c'est même une d'aucune des doctrines
principal dans plusieurs pays aux états
unis il est pratiqué depuis longtemps en
allemagne maintenant en angleterre aussi
de façon assez massive en france c'est
un petit peu difficile c'est utilisé de
façon très ponctuelle par quelques
utilisateurs
parce que tout le monde attend tout le
monde a la volonté de l'utiliser mais
tout le monde attend ces dernières
autorisations et dont effectivement la
position de la hs est finalement une
étape une étape pourquoi parce que elle
était associée aussi à des
préconisations d'utilisation sur les
symptomatique et j'aimerais revenir sur
ce point les symptomatique c'est très
bien mais finalement est-ce bien là la
population qui vous visent et qu'il faut
viser lorsque l'on souhaite enrayer la
propagation du virus
aujourd'hui on voit cet engorgement que
vous avez décrit tout à l'heure dans
votre sujet et peut-être que la
stratégie serait d'autant plus
intéressante qu'elle cible les personnes
susceptibles de propager le virus et
sans le savoir
donc les uns symptomatiques sont une
population intéressante où effectivement
les cas contactez aller en ce qui nous
concerne nous on observe des choses très
intéressantes dans la salive
ça a été vu par d'eau de groupe à
l'international qui montre que la salive
comme l'a montré la chaise et bien un
milieu intéressant pour aller mesurer le
les russes et qu'il peut elle peut être
employée y compris assez précocement
c'est vrai que alexandre à apprieu il a
il ya quelques mois on pensait qu'on ne
pouvait pas de détecter le co2 19 dans
la salive 1 c'est bien cela alors en
effet on va dire que au départ on a
vraiment commencé par le prélèvement
nasopharyngé je dirais que c'était un
petit peu l'état actuel des choses et
c'était un peu la façon dont les tests
se faisait en biologie nous de notre
côté avec franck très très trop tôt dans
la crise
on a pris le pari de la salive notamment
sur ce constat qui paraît terriblement
simple qui est c'est un virus qui se
transmet notamment par les postillons
donc nous avons voulu aller voir s'il y
avait du virus dans la
saliver c'est ce pour quoi nous nous
sommes battus dès le départ alors franck
molina aujourd'hui si je souhaite faire
un test salivaire parce que j'ai des
doutes ou parce que je dois aller
prendre un avion par exemple comment est
ce que je peux faire
aujourd'hui en france et bien c'est pas
très très claires puisque la
préconisation de la chaîne c'est une
première étape
mais aujourd'hui il faut mettre en place
et s et l'hiver sur le terrain et donc
je pense que ça va nécessiter quelques
jours et quelques semaines je suppose
que certains laboratoires en ayant
entendu ces propositions de la chaise
vont maintenant se mettre à ce type de
test et c'est bien aux alexandrins
prions donc c'est bien cela ce sera les
lacs ce seront les laboratoires qui
feront ce type de test où on pourra le
faire ailleurs je pense notamment aux
pharmacies ou pourquoi pas chez les
médecins
alors aujourd'hui selon la
réglementation française ça doit passer
par un laboratoire de biologie médicale
ou à laboratoires hospitaliers
pour faire simple il est possible
d'élargir et de changer la
réglementation mais là ça dépend de
monsieur ministre a et en ce qui
concerne le remboursement ce sera donc
le même cas que pour les tests pc
aujourd'hui je crois que la chaise qui
doit prendre des décisions à ce sujet et
donc spécifiquement pour l'heure les
tests salivaires
je suppose que c'est des choses qui sont
acquis sont en débat et que aléas les
réponses à ces questions vont venir
j'espère très vite à pour conclure
franck molina effectivement aujourd'hui
il ya la volonté de désengorger les
laboratoires ces nouveaux tests
salivaires c'est l'une des solutions
selon vous oui pourquoi parce que pour
deux raisons c'est que quelles que
soient leurs performances qui sont de
toute façon acceptable même si elles
peuvent être quelquefois un petit peu
inférieur aux laboratoires
la première chose c'est que la
population n'acceptera très facilement
et donc pour les uns symptomatique les
gens qui ne sont pas malades mais qui
veulent se faire tester il ya une
acceptation plus grande et l'autre point
c'est que ces tests peuvent aussi être
réalisées sur le terrain et là on va
aller dans un second point qui est la
récurrence des tests quand on veut
vraiment réduire le taux de propagation
du virus on a besoin de faire des tests
avec des répétitions quelquefois il
suffit pas d'être testé une fois dans sa
vie pour ne pas être infecté un peu plus
tard et donc il va être important de
penser à une stratégie qui soit à la
fois présent sur le terrain simple dans
coran est aussi qui permettent une
récurrence des tests parce que sinon on
n'arrivera pas à utiliser les tests pour
enrayer cette épidémie
un dernier mot justement alexandrie au
combien de temps pour avoir les
résultats avec un test salivaire
lorsque nous vous avions annoncé au mois
de mai mais semble-t-il c'était une
heure et aujourd'hui avec les équipes
dodd-frank nous avons continué les
travaux est donc à présent et demain ce
sera 40 minutes donc c'est extrêmement
rapide et bien merci beaucoup en tout
cas à tous les deux d'avoir répondu à
nos questions alexandre appris que je
rappelle que vous êtes pdg de skills
elle merci à vous franck molina
directeur de recherche au cnrs